uh hello everyone again the next speaker
is iman ayari and she will be talking
about
uh shockwave inspired rifle for data
analysis
iman is uh has just finished her had
just had her master's degree last
from
in data science for business uh she is
currently working as a lead data analyst
and a project manager at datagram a of a
french tech company especially in
e-retail and e-commerce and then and
analytics
all right even now the flaw is yours
for the session goals uh i i needed i i
feel like i had the need to talk about
okay code project in data-driven jobs
because uh something that i have
witnessed myself
um
second thing is um
testing testing is something
which is very very
needed in software development projects
and it's actually something um which
when it's not there it's a problem
the third thing is towards modeler
slash design
um
so um
why do we need a workflow um this is a
question that i have asked myself before
doing this presentation and i have tried
to
kind of
brainstorm with myself to
uh to see if i'm in the in the right
track to why do we need a workflow or
and if we actually need it in data in
data-driven jobs as a data analyst um i
actually see myself doing a lot of
scripts sometimes
i use a lot of jupiter notebooks
because i feel like some things
[Music]
some rituals that i do are repetitive
and so
um something that i have learned from
my
from some personal
uh and
study project in indian university in
software for example is that abstraction
is superior to implementation what does
that mean is uh we as a data analyst or
data scientist when we face some
problems we go uh
and we go find solutions for our key
problems um in
i don't know say a stack overflow for
example or
over the internet and then we kind of
had the
um
the reflex for example to just copy and
paste especially when we are in jupiter
not risk for example and so this habit
is uh makes us
depending more and more on
implementation and not abstractions
when we depend on abstractions
we define a clear
path for
um
for our work um it will be reproducible
it's easily tested and um
we can collaborate more with our
teammates if you're working on a team
for example
um second thing uh
why do we need a workflow we need a
workflow because when having a workflow
uh we need a workflow actually which has
testing habits which has testing
um
[Music]
repositories for example uh and this
habit i think in data driven jobs need
to be
implemented and
followed
in in
all of the projects because testing uh
will make us
do reproducible uh will make us do a
reliable code
and a code which is um which
gives us instant feedback
about um
the for example um i don't know
uh
it will give us instant feedbacks about
the quality of our code if we are not
testing we do not know if we
have some things or if we
have forgot some use case for example
the third thing is easier automation and
better collaboration and it strikes me
sometimes that we are selfishly
coding
in notebooks for example or like
transforming to scripts to daily scripts
that we are we do not think of our
teammates or we do not think about tea
uh the next person which is gone to to
come and
work on our code when it's not when it's
not clear and it's not following um
let's say or a clear
a clear
[Music]
a clear design
it's it's more
it's it's actually more difficult to
understand and to work on um and so it's
it's not scalable
um and last thing i think um
for example virtual environments which
is the
thing um in python project
sometimes it's not enough
to it's not enough setup for our project
for example
uh when working with python locally on
the cpu um
pytorch
we would
the software there for example would um
think of creating a make file
if you don't know what the make file is
a make file is
is a file which uh inside we can list
some instructions and these instructions
we give to the system and tell him to
uh and tell it um
to execute
these rules or these command lines
in that order for example or as as
written in the make file
so this is a live example for um
why
um
virtual environment for example is it's
not enough because we need more than
that to uh to make this the setup for
for
a certain example uh of a project for
example
um
so um
next on is um the next right question
that i had asked myself was how does
archaism look like in a project
um and i think this is an easy question
because um i have seen this so many
times in my projects in my private
projects in university or
personal projects when i started
learning data
uh data analysis and data science um so
archaism
uh when it's the chaos in your
representative
when you have multiple unnamed proper
leisure terminal books so you end up
with indian title one and entitled two
an entitled test etc
uh so you end up with a with a
never-ending list of unentitled chapter
notebooks
um
[Music]
which is which is not good in the long
run because
at some point you would need to go back
and check something or you need to go
back and
borrow let's say a piece of code from
that jupiter notebook or let's say that
you want to
make it reproducible for example so
it's like doing the same all over again
every time
our case
also
looks in
we identify our case in no clear designs
no clear designs when we have
um uh
not a clear structure which can help us
test our code easily
um not a defined pipeline of course
because sometimes um we have
a separate jobs
uh
script jobs for
tiny little thing tiny very defined
little things and um
we
we take a lot of time to assemble let's
say a defined pipeline and um we can
lose so many times because we're not
testing it
we're not testing our code and so we can
lose so many time
trying to define our pipeline
um so here i'm going to uh
um
jump
quickly
to um
what i have prepared
so um just
stop sharing and i will share again
another
screen
so
um
i have tried to um
to construct a
little project
a small project which illustrates for
example archaism versus
a tested code
in which i have implemented a cultural
environment a jupiter notebook
for example and so here the um
my code
so this is my first jupyter notebook for
example
so the idea is to um
read
a qr code and to um
decode it or read what's decoded in in
the qr code so this is actually a very
first step in in a project for example
um very simple um and so here uh as a
first step what i
need to do in every
like every other project so i make a
solo 2 for my imports here i'm going to
import my um pillow
uh and i'm going to import my key bar
for decoding the
the um the images
um
and so um after that um i just going to
um
[Music]
uh open load the the picture and and
read it and then afterwards i i just
need to like print the output of the
data and encoded
um
in in my main project
in a project like this if i need to to
go from
a jupiter notebook to
a script or an executable python file uh
what i
use the first reflex is make my imports
and then reproduce the same things but
here um not in cell oriented uh
you know like format but rather in an
executable python file with with written
codes yeah etc
um
here for example um
in my
even if my my my project is um
is called archaism um i have
the reflex um to show the make file so
here is a make file my make file is for
linux for example to set up my
uh my linux environment
uh to install
libraries to activate my
virtual environment to install
requirements etc and then to run it to
run the python main dot peep
um
so here i have all my requirements i
have my virtual environment etc so when
i
when i execute
this make file uh when it's saying like
[Music]
make
[Music]
make clinics here and
just go to this
and then i will be having everything
which i need to be installed here um as
installed
um next up is um
[Music]
this when when we see our casing like
this
um it's not it's not a good project it's
not a very
um appealing code um
even if it's the very first steps
we have a clear idea that what's coming
next it's not going to be as as good
um and so the next project is
the project where i called testis doubt
test is there because um
we are constantly putting into checks
our code and the quality of our code
because
all what we
we want is um
[Music]
a code which is reproducible which is
clean which is um
which is not
going to be
a headache
when we move on to the next steps of the
project and so just it does this doubt
we we still have um a jupiter notebook
but um here uh
we have commented our our notebook for
example so um
in the in the last jupiter notebook we
we don't have any clear idea of what we
have what we're doing in the cells if
not for um reading the code and trying
to understand
uh what exactly we are doing
and so um
this is how to decode a qr code with uh
pzba
um so next up um i'm going to do my
import classic
um then
the idea is to
document or to make comments
um every step of the road
and so here i'm uploading a locally
stored image which is my qr code
right here this is my qr code which says
um
[Music]
by data with a little smiley
um and so after that i'm going to read
my my output
uh and i'm going to to decode it and
when decoding it we can see here that we
have a list of objects um with um
a lot of
a lot of other information about the
type about the shape
et cetera and we here we are we are only
interested in the data the data part um
so um
another another comment of course
to to specify what we need to do in the
next the next step
and here we say that we want to work
only with the value included in the qr
code and so when i execute this
cell right here
it will just tell me pie data with them
with a little smiling
okay cool
um so now um
going going back from from this
to um
trying to
structure my code um i thought about
having um
a circle
[Music]
and then inside it i'm going to have a
qr code and
last but not least i'm going to have
domain.p and the main will execute
everything in order as i want it and so
in the decode.p
um here
i will probably think of making a
function so get data from qr code
we need the
the str as the path
of the of the qr code image
and then after that i'm just going to
return
the data encoded
so here as as we say
as we see it's it's different from my
other
main.pi
function
and
my main dot pi
would probably look something like this
in the other code in the archaism code
for example we didn't have any
cis ugly um
params for example and um we didn't have
the
the the main as
as a main as defined in in python uh we
didn't have any imports um everything
was
done in that instance for that code
specifically
um and so here um classic i'm just going
to
import my my function give it the path
that i set right here and then print the
value and here if i needed
to check my make file um
so i have my virtual environment set up
except for my requirements etc
and then
and i have
the test
so uh if i need to run this code for
example
yes so make run it will
run the uh this instance from my virtual
environment
um
so
it's clear that
by data
and then if i want to
[Music]
test it because good code needs good
tests um so here i have added
some tests
so right here the test
should
um test should get value from qr code
uh here i i have followed a ranch act
assert
for um
uh for testing and so for example if i
needed to run my test to see
my my um
my my val the value in um
[Music]
in the qr code uh says
pi data for example is it does it really
save my data i'll just do make
tests
and then um it says yes correct um it
does stay like that however if i needed
to for example
uh change something and make this and
here i'm going to find
immediately that it's failed and so
probably um i have uploaded the wrong
uh qr code for example
or something like that
um
so um
that's that's um that's about it
and um
next
um
[Music]
the next thing that we would think about
probably is to um
set a modular
architecture or design uh for example i
am a very
um
fan of
um
hexagonal architecture i find it very
interesting and very modular i find it
very specific and um it's easily tested
so um
it's it's a good example to
to to follow on and
and to learn actually because um
we need to
always um set up something and then
follow it it's like making a plan and
then following it along with the builds
step by step
um
so uh just going back to my presentation
real quick
you might excuse me you have four
minutes left yes uh thank you very much
uh we are about to
um
[Music]
to get to the end of the presentation um
so um
right here we talked about uh how does
artisan look like
um
and then um
the testing the testing is is needed
because we need to construct more robust
and reliable code
and um
the the the last question is why do i
gain
how what do i gain from a clear design
pattern uh which i have um answer
right right now i guess uh it is better
code easier benchmark for for my
algorithms if i'm a data scientist and i
work with a lot of algorithms for
example um reliable code for example and
scalability reproducible code etc
um so that's that's about it for for
this presentation um thank you very much
for following along
and um
[Music]
please if you have any questions
i think there is one question about unit
tests for from thomas about unit tests
are for specifically return testing
return values against a test case how
does this help with experimental
analysis in real life i think you can
answer this one before we move to the
next presentation
all right
um uh it does it does help um for
example if we are having uh
large deficits uh and we are not
i don't know if we want to make a mock
uh out of that data set for example or
if we want to test if our connection
with the database for the external
database is is
is working um all the unit tests will
help us do that um and
probably not exactly in the exploratory
part because that depends on the very
implementation of
uh the datasheet
as we are
going step by step but um for
everything like connection like um
database
data extraction etc it's very very
helpful um i have tried it in
so many projects and
it works like charm and it's life savior
uh i hope that i have answered you
okay thank you eamon and let's move on
to the
um next presentation